Ever bumped into a glass door?
It seems like bats do it pretty often,
and not because they’re texting.
A new study shows that bats fail to recognize
human-made vertical, smooth surfaces,
like glass windows, as obstacles.
The researchers placed a vertical metal plate
in the corner of a flight tunnel.
Then, they monitored bats as they flew through it.
Of 21 bats, 19 crashed at least once into the plate,
but never into walls or other objects
Collisions also occurred when the researchers
placed the metal plates outside of caves of
three different bat species.
This is because smooth surfaces limit bats’ ability
to navigate through the dark using
their echolocation system.
Bats emit high-frequency sounds
and use the returning echoes
to spot obstacles in their surroundings.
But a sleek, vertical surface approached at an angle
reflects away the echoes,
fooling bats into recognizing them as open flyways.
The scientists now hope to determine if
windows or glass buildings pose an ecological threat
to bats and how these animals
can learn to deal with them.